ici chaque semaine la guerre des débuts
entraîne de nouvelles bavures
à l'hôpital de la ville Christian est
venu voir son petit frère
c'est un jeune berger qui a rencontré
une armée sur les nerfs
ce matin-là je suis allé tout à l'étable
pour voir les ébus comme tous les jours
j'ai entendu des gens crier dalle dalle
j'ai cru que des voleurs arrivaient
alors j'ai pris mon arme et je suis
sorti
en fait c'était des militaires ils m'ont
dit jette ton arme
c'est ce que j'ai fait mais après ça ils
m'ont quand même tiré dessus
j'ai pris une balle dans la main là
juste ici et l'autre je l'ai prise dans
la jambe
j'espère que je vais m'en sortir
mais on nous dit que l'armée aurait fait
bien pire que de blesser un enfant c'est
dans les petits villages aux alentours
que les militaires ont frappé le plus
durement
Farah 18 ans elle cherche en vain un
vestige dans les décombres de sa maison
il ne reste plus rien de la maison les
militaires ont tout brûlé et volé tout
ce qui avait de la valeur
nous découvrons un village entier que
les militaires viennent d'incendier
une expédition punitive sans enquête sur
la seule fois d'une dénonciation
les soldats est une liste de noms de
supposés Dahl tous membres de la famille
de Farah
les militaires étaient nombreux ils sont
passés par là
ils ont ordonné à mon frère mon neveu et
mon cousin de s'asseoir contre ce mur
alors pour être sûr les militaires ont
dit c'est quoi le nom du village
puis ils ont demandé les noms les gens
ont donné leur nom alors les militaires
se sont mis à tirés mon neveu a pris une
balle dans la poitrine
mon frère a pris une première balle dans
la cuisse puis lui ont tiré dans le
bassin et une dernière dans la tête les
deux sont morts mon cousin s'est évanoui
ils ne l'ont pas tué après les
militaires se sont mis à brûler les
maisons une par une tout le village
accusé d'avoir volé des ébules le frère
de Farah avait pourtant été disculpé au
tribunal et reconnu innocent mais le
soupçon et la volonté de revanche de
l'armée longtemps porté
je suis triste et en colère en tuant mon
frère les militaires ont tué un innocent
ils n'étaient pas d'âge c'est lui qui
nous nourrissait moi et les enfants nous
n'avons plus rien pour vivre maintenant
dans ce village calciné écrasé de soleil
le dernier refuge c'est le grand
manguier et son nombre protectrice les
habitants s'y sont réfugiés autour de
leur chef
à chaque fois qu'on entend un bruit de
moteur on se dit que ça peut être les
militaires alors on préfère fuir dans la
forêt vous savez avant notre village
prenait de l'ampleur c'était un beau
village on a les mêmes y installer un
marché
des populations brisées
livrées à elle-même
ici la violence de l'État est aussi
aveugle que celle des bandits
partout le manque de moyens amplifie les
erreurs de jugement
la distance freine sans cesse la vérité
et fait grandir la légende des dahls les
voleurs de zébus de Madagascar